geht es ihnen wie mir brauchen sie einen
digitalen upgrade für die vernetzte und
komplexe welt von morgen jemand der uns
helfen kann und eine klare idee davon
hat wie wir teil einer smarten digitalen
gesellschaft der zukunft werden könnten
ist der komplexität forscher der kelvin
kundentag sieht sie ein visionär
das ist schwer zu beurteilen ich befasse
mich einfach mit fragen der gesellschaft
und der technologischen entwicklung wie
diese zwei dinge zusammen spielen also
die technologie unsere gesellschaft und
wirtschaft verändern wird und insofern
muss man schon den blick in die zukunft
wagen natürlich kann man die nicht genau
voraussagen aber es gibt schon
verschiedene szenarien die man durch
spielen kann wenn sie sagen szenarien
wie man durch spielen kann dann hat das
auch etwas mit einer art von welt
simulationen zu tun
na ja im grunde genommen wird daran
gearbeitet denke ich und die
computersysteme heutzutage sind eben
extrem leistungsfähig das werden auch
immer mehr daten verfügbar
um gleichzeitig steht die menschheit
natürlich für riesen großen problemen
das heißt da liegt es nahe diese daten
und auch die computerbauer zu benutzen
um diese probleme zu lösen und
komplexität forschung das klingt ja
schon selbst kompliziert wie kommt man
eigentlich darauf ja nun gut ich meine
durch die vernetzungen wo die welt immer
komplexer und das macht sie natürlich
auch interessant sie differenziert sich
immer mehr aus die märkte entwickeln
immer mehr produkte die kultur wird
immer diffiziler und die interaktion
zwischen den verschiedenen kulturen
aber gleichzeitig ist es ist auch der
motor der innovation der motor des
fortschritts
wir sind sie selbst auf dieses
arbeitsfeld gekommen ja ich hatte damals
ein professor manfred schröder
der hat uns einfach sehr fasziniert und
hat uns damals die welt der komplexen
systeme näher gebracht da ist da ging es
um chaos und fraktale insbesondere um
selbstorganisation und die machen mich
nicht mehr los
aber das war quasi der physiker dirk
entspricht aber seine art
erweckungserlebnis haben in göttingen
studiert ja das hatte seinen grund
damals war götting eine der großen
physik städte berühmte professoren waren
dort gewesen in der vergangenheit und so
wollte ich eben über das kleinste und
das größte im universum lernen wie die
meisten physikstudenten aber dann im
laufe der zeit dachte ich mir dass wir
vielleicht schön sich auch mit der
realen welt mehr auseinander zu setzen
und um diese zeit gab es konflikte in
götting zwischen neonazis das war lange
bevor man über das problem diskutiert
hat und autonom und zwischen denen gab
es immer wieder zusammenstöße
auch die polizei griff gelegentlich ein
und einer dieser polizeieinsatz lief
schief in gewisser weise als kam jemand
ums leben
und das hat eine große empörung in der
öffentlichkeit ausgelöst
es gab riesige demonstration diese
demonstrationen gingen anders aus als
die große öffentlichkeit erwartet hatte
also es ging scheiben zu bruch
es gab riesige diskussion hinterher man
wusste eigentlich nicht wie damit es mit
der situation umzugehen sei
und dann gab es eben im theater
öffentliche diskussion über konflikte
und gewalt und was eigentlich die
richtige art und weise sei mit diesen
dingen umzugehen und mir wurde klar dass
die teilnehmer aneinander vorbeireden
und damals habe ich den entschluss
gefasst man muss das thema
wissenschaftlich angehen und gesagt
getan ich habe dann angefangen eben auch
psychologie und soziologie kurse zu
nehmen
dann hat mir überlegt was möchte ich mit
meiner diplomarbeit machen
und hab dann viele arbeiten studiert und
drei themen standen am ende zur auswahl
die ich interessant fand es eine wahre
trösten dass andere gruppendynamik und
das dritte fußgängerströme und das ist
dritte thema war im grunde genommen
jenes was ich am meisten für eine physik
diplom arbeit ereignet und deswegen habe
ich das begonnen es war damals
eigentlich noch kein richtiges
forschungsthema schon gar nicht in der
physik aber später zehn jahre später
weil es ein großes thema und es ist ja
dann tatsächlich auch in praktische
anwendungen gemündet also heutzutage
gibt es software um großveranstaltungen
zu planen die zum teil eben auch unsere
modelle benutzt und andererseits haben
wir auch in mekka zum beispiel uns die
lage angeschaut um massen unglücke in
zukunft möglichst zu vermeiden also viel
wurde da umorganisiert und also das
heißt sie haben wie 1 1 ein gerät ein
tool entwickelt mit dem sie die massen
strömen so steuern können dass weniger
unfälle passiert also dieses tool gibt
ihnen eine gewisse macht wie ist es wenn
man sie nennen das manchmal auch eine
art von kristallkugel wenn man so eine
kristallkugel hat
was gibt einem das für ein gefühl nun ja
wir selber haben keine kristallkugel da
darf ich sie beruhigen und der plan ist
auch nicht eine solche zu bauen das
würde uns manchmal nachgesagt aber unser
ansatz ist eigentlich ein anderes
dennoch ist es wichtig glaube ich über
diese möglichkeit oder unmöglichkeit
eine kristallkugel zu bauen zu reden
denn das hat wesentliche implikationen
für unsere gesellschaft
ja also große staaten sind natürlich in
der lage unglaublich mächtige
informations tools zu bauen die frage
ist ja was passiert da eigentlich also
das heißt sie sie als wissenschaftler
aus forschung arbeiten mit diesen
informationsströme mit dieser
informationen die da ist sie kennen die
chancen die gefahren
sie sagen dass wir in einer technischen
revolution stream stecken wie muss man
sich diese technische revolution ganz
konkret vorstellen jetzt vielleicht das
ganz nützlich mal zurück zu schauen wie
das begann vor einigen jahrzehnten ja
der computer wurde erfunden aber zu der
zeit hat ibm chef watson noch geglaubt
dass es vielleicht ein weltmarkt für
film computer geht man da ja 50 jahre
zurück bestimmt wenn ich mehr und dann
muss man natürlich sagen dass ein großer
irrtum
woran lag das ja man hat irgendwann
begonnen die computer miteinander zu
vernetzen
zunächst gab es ab annett ein
militärisches netzwerk und das wurde
dann aber geöffnet das internet entstand
und schließlich kann
tim berners lee derweil übrigens am cern
hier in der schweiz und hat ein
protokoll entwickelt um letzten endes
webseiten miteinander zu vernetzen als
world wide web erfunden und das hat das
internet letzten endes erschlossen für
nicht-experten plötzlich entstand ein
multi milliarden markt also die digitale
ökonomie wurde dadurch möglich und dann
schließlich von nicht einmal zehn jahren
hätte das der bürger eigentlich gedacht
dass das passieren würde kam eben
einerseits iphones und tabletts und so
weiter aber eben auch twitter und
facebook also soziale netzwerke und wir
sind eigentlich alle ein bestandteil
dieses riesen großen globalen
informations systems geworden und zwar
sind wir einerseits nun nutzer aber
andererseits eben auch datenlieferanten
prozessoren in gewisser weise und auch
produkte und das kann man natürlich
kriegt ist
wir sind das internet kamen uns immer
näher kann man sagen aber wir sind also
sie haben die 22 players genannt die
ökonomie die wirtschaft das militär der
staat und jetzt wir alle genau und wie
wie sehen sie alle damit eingebunden
hier im grunde genommen ist es so dass
mit jeder aktivität wir heutzutage
machen daten in stehen und auch dann
wenn wir unser leben nicht im netz
veröffentlichen also über facebook zum
beispiel entstehen unglaublich viele
daten ja beim shoppen in dem wir uns
bewegen mit unseren smartphones und so
weiter und so fort
und viele dieser daten werden eben auch
abgegriffen wenn wir nicht damit
einverstanden sind also auf unserem
laptop oder computer sind sagen jetzt 20
prozesse unterwegs die mit schreiben was
wir tun ja cook lesen super cookies zum
beispiel und jeder klick wird im grund
genommen aufgezeichnet die firmen die
das tun sind oft kleine unbekannte
firmen aber diese kaufen diese daten
weiter an alle anderen firmen
wahrscheinlich auch an öffentliche
institutionen
vielleicht auch in die geheimdienste
also ist er ein riesige datensammlung
geschaffen und das dient einerseits
natürlich der profitmaximierung also die
produkte besser an den langen die frau
zu bringen und dafür muss man quasi
wissen wer interessiert sich für was
also das sind wir mitten schon in den in
den risiken drin die sie skizzieren aber
noch einmal auf die auf die maschinerie
gewissermaßen also diese künstliche
intelligenz wie lange geht das noch bis
der computer wirklich dass hier um das
menschliche gehirn überrollt hat in
seiner kapazität ja darüber gibt es
verschiedene meinungen also kurzweil
harzburg musste dass das in etwa zehn
jahren der fall sein wird es gibt ja
auch ohne auch dieses jungen ren projekt
hier in der schweiz nicht ohne grund
manche glauben dass das vielleicht 25
jahre dauern würde manche glauben hast
du vielleicht schon in fünf jahren
heißt es wieder passieren im grunde
genommen ist es so dass wir um die ibm
wie google apple und wahrscheinlich auch
öffentliche institutionen an künstlicher
intelligenz im großen maßstab arbeiten
wahrscheinlich darüber wird nicht viel
geschrieben
jetzt gab es gerade von baidu eine kurze
pressemitteilung das ist die große
chinesische suchmaschinen dass sie nach
militärischen finanzmitteln sucht und
kooperation um letzten endes eine
künstliche intelligenz im großen maßstab
zu bauen
man darf sich natürlich fragen ob das
nicht anders wo auch schon gemacht
wurden möglicherweise seit vielen jahren
es gibt ja seit einiger zeit jetzt
einige alarmierte stimmen von leuten die
sicherlich sich gut auskennen den mast
zum beispiel von tesla motors aber auch
bill gates oder stephen hawkings ja
manche meinen das sei die größte
bedrohung der menschheit wenn ich das
vor drei jahren das erste mal gelesen
habe dachte ich das ist lächerlich ja
heutzutage muss man das wahrscheinlich
doch ernst an denen oder das heißt
eigenen die gefahren liegen darin dass
die maschinen uns vom sockel als krönung
der schöpfung stoßen werden und die
macht übernehmen ja ob sie die macht
übernehmen das ist eine andere frage
zunächst einmal brauchen wir glaube ich
tatsächlich informationssysteme die uns
assistieren
weil die welt tatsächlich komplexer
geworden ist und zum beispiel arbeitet
am cognitive computing und das im
letzten endes systeme die einfach viel
mehr informationen verarbeiten und
überschauen können das ist ein mensch
kann ja die ganze medizinische literatur
ist in der zehntausende von
veröffentlichung kein mensch kann das
lesen
ein solcher computer kann ist innerhalb
von 15 minuten einlesen und folglich
daneben auch all dieses wissen ausnutzen
dass menschen
über jahrzehnte hinweg produziert haben
die idee ist aber nicht dass diese
maschinen die ärzte ersetzen sondern
dass es sie unterstützen und das wird
bei anderen berufsgruppen auch der fall
sein aber werden da nicht tausende
millionen von von jobs gestrichen werden
in dieser entwicklung die ja so dass ich
alle stellt sich die frage sicherlich
stellt sich die frage wie sich das ganze
entwickelt und viele leute in der it
industrie im silicon valley sehen
tatsächlich das problem dass die
prozesse die wir heutzutage eben als
menschen selber machen immer stärker
automatisiert werden können
und viele von den jobs die wir
heutzutage wahrnehmen von computern oder
algorithmen oder robotern wahrgenommen
werden also in etwa 20 jahren muss man
damit rechnen dass 50 prozent der
industriellen jobs und 50 prozent der
service jobs verloren gehen dann würde
das bedeuten dass alle drei klassischen
sektoren und ökonomie das heißt die
landwirtschaft industrie und service
weniger als 50 prozent der jobs zur
verfügung stellen
es müssen also mindestens 50 prozent
neue jobs im digitalen sektor entstehen
das ist also der neue sektor der jetzt
quasi die alten herausfordert war jetzt
plötzlich viele dinge auf neue art und
weise organisiert werden können viel
viel viel effizienter daran ist also
hier sind wir in einer
gesellschaftlichen revolution bringen
das wird sicherlich die wirtschaft
völlig umkrempeln
ich denke viele bereiche und in unserer
gesellschaft auch also die art und weise
wie wir shoppen hat sich schon lange
geändert aber eben auch die art und
weise wie wir uns fortbewegen wenn wir
dann selbst fahrende fahrzeuge haben
vielleicht werden uns die güter die wir
im internet bestellen irgendwann mit
drohnen
geliefert das durchaus machbar dann ist
es natürlich so dass wir in der
wissenschaft jetzt zunehmend auf daten
zum teil auch big data zurückgreifen
können das ändert auch letzten endes die
erkenntnis prozesse die methoden die wir
anwenden
wir werden sehen dass personalisierte
medizin wichtig wird die wird uns helfen
menschen gezielter zu behandeln
jeder reagiert unterschiedlich auf
medikamente jeder hat unterschiedliche
nebenwirkungen insofern kann man die
medikamente viel besser einstellen auf
person und vielleicht sogar verhindern
dass man krank wird indem man das war
sozusagen die symptome sie die
möglicherweise zu einer kann also das
heißt es gibt es gibt prozesse die sinn
in die daten hineingeben in einem
positiven sinn was aber wo sind die
grenzen von big data was kann es nicht
es gibt einige herausforderungen von big
data ich meine ist eine technologie die
andere technologien das heißt es gibt
auch unerwünschte nebenwirkung ein
problem ist dass mehr daten nicht
unbedingt bedeutet dass man bessere
erkenntnisse gewinnt es gibt das problem
dass opa fittings das also letzten endes
die modelle zufälligkeiten angefüttert
werden und das hat dann nachher nichts
zu bedeuten also man spricht in diesem
zusammenhang von skurrile chance das
heißt von irgendwelchen zusammenhängen
die nachher gar nichts bedeuten spielt
ja nun gut wenn wir abends uns den
himmel anschauen dann glauben wir da
gewisse sternzeichen zu sehen und das
natürlich muster die wir da hinein
deuten aber die letzten endes nach
wissenschaftlicher meinung nichts zu
bedeuten haben
das gleiche kann letzten endes eben auch
passieren mit
aber viel größeres problem ist
eigentlich dass man gute und schlechte
risiken voneinander trennen möchte ja
gesundheitsrisiken oder
kreditausfallrisiken oder was auch immer
oder ob jemand ein terrorist ist oder
nicht und es stellt sich eben heraus
dass man meistens keine klare trennung
vornehmen kann das heißt es gibt immer
zweifelsfälle und damit entstehen fehler
so genannte fehler erster und zweiter
art also fehlalarme wo jemand für einen
terroristen gehalten wird obwohl das gar
nicht ist oder situation wo jemand
tatsächlich ein terrorist ist aber eben
nicht als solcher rechtzeitig erkannt
wurde
all diese fälle hatten wir natürlich in
der vergangenheit aber auch für den
normalen bürger hat das letzten endes
implikationen also sieht man das
beispiel versicherung oder kredit ja da
ist es nun natürlich möglich dass man
viel besser einschätzt wie sich
lebensumstände auswirken können auf
gesundheitliche risiken oder eben auch
auf den ausfall des kredits und da
spielen dann möglicherweise
unabsichtlich auch variablen hinein die
wir eigentlich gar nicht unterscheiden
möchten wie zum beispiel
wir möchten frauen nicht diskriminieren
dafür dass sie beim kinderkriegen
sozusagen zusätzliche gesundheitskosten
verursachen sondern also keine größere
gesundheitsprämie bezahlen
genauso wollen wir nicht menschen
diskriminieren nach ethnizität danach
religion oder nach sexueller
orientierung oder dergleichen aber all
diese dinge könnten quasi bei den big
data algorithmen daher eine rolle
spielen für den preis sind nicht
bezahlen muss oder ob ich eben eine
krankenversicherung bekommen die ich
haben möchte oder den kredit oder nicht
zu unterbrechen
das heißt dictator macht uns nicht
krisensicher
weil es diese unschärfen oder diese
diese nicht klaren konsequenzen aus den
daten immer noch gibt na ja es ist weil
wie bei jedem instrument man kann es für
gut und für schlechte zwecke gebraucht
und unter umständen stellt sich als
zehnter heraus ob es gut oder schlecht
aber ich zum beispiel ganz konkret ist
partnersuche über das internet das heißt
ich kann ja meine daten eingeben und
suche den idealen partner und wenn ich
hier aber nicht nicht sicher bin was
passiert dann kommt bekomme ich den
falschen also die falsche
ja das ist natürlich ein risiko was in
allen bereichen passieren kann ich
wollte aber auf einen punkt zu sprechen
kommt er eigentlich viel wichtiger ist
dass nämlich letzten endes unser
soziales umfeld da auch mit 1 geht in
alle diese berechnungen
das heißt obwohl ich vielleicht meine
nachbarn nicht gesehen habe mit denen
gar nichts zu tun habe beeinflussen die
letzten endes die angebote die ich
bekommen also auch die kaufangebote und
insofern ist es so dass hier dinge in
meinem leben hinein spielen
die ich gar nicht beeinflussen kann
damit verliere ich sozusagen autonomie
über mein leben und das ist letzten
endes die gefahr wenn wir die daten so
verwenden wie es heutzutage tun weil da
nämlich die informationelle
selbstbestimmung nicht wie der einfluss
die nachbarschaft mein verhalten
ja es kann zum beispiel sein dass da
irgendein nachbar den kredit nicht
zurückgezahlt hat und dass man dann
daraus schließt ja möglicherweise liegt
das an der nachbarschaft der vielleicht
ist es das soziale umfeld nun
möglicherweise gibt es dann in zukunft
auch weitere ausfälle und das wirkt sich
dann so aus dass man eine höhere prämie
also höhere zinsen bezahlen
ich habe ein bisschen ski team quasi die
wehr von von daten spricht heutzutage
sie sprechen davon dass es das r des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert ist das
ist sehr starke finanziellen finanzielle
interessen dahinter stehen das so macht
geht und power die privatsphäre das ist
für uns alle quasi der heiße punkt ist
die ist die gibt es schutz in diesem
system drin oder müssen wir so etwas ist
mir die privatsphäre fahren lassen als
altmodisches konzept ja das ist ja sehr
viele themen gewesen ich denke wir
müssen wir einzeln beleuchtet
zum einen ist es tatsächlich so dass mit
daten nun völlig neue geschäftsfelder
aufkommen völlig neue möglichkeiten und
das natürlich interessant für ressourcen
arme länder wie zb europäische länder
daten produzieren auch praktisch keine
umweltverschmutzung ja energieverbrauch
erscheinen doch vertretbar zu sein und
insofern ist das schon letzten endes ein
sehr interessanter ökonomischer bereich
es auch ein bereich wo es sozusagen
keine begrenzung gibt wie wir sie in der
materiellen welt
daten lassen sich so auch wir wollen
reproduzieren
ja es lassen sich virtuelle welten
schafften spielewelten zum beispiel und
es gibt immer mehr menschen die
tatsächlich auch mit diesen spielewelten
den virtuellen welten geld verdienen
also da entstehen völlig neue
wirtschafts und soziale kosten im grunde
genau ja digitale cosman die sind aber
vernetzt mit unserer wert also sehr
interessante möglichkeiten und
perspektiven die man sich sicherlich
nicht entgehen lassen kann der staat
nicht die wirtschaftlich und der bürger
möchte das auch nicht nun ist eben die
frage welchen preis muss man dafür
zahlen
und das hängt wiederum davon ab wie wir
die daten benutzen das heißt wie wir die
informationssysteme organisieren und ich
denke dass wir da tatsächlich auch
einiges besser machen können und müssen
als wir das in der vergangenheit gemacht
war war die affäre um schneiden und so
etwas wie ein augenöffner wie so ein
moment wo wir alle gemerkt
juli da passiert etwas wo wir überhaupt
nicht uns bewusst waren eine entwicklung
die wir sogar verschlafen haben und ja
das ist sicherlich so europa glaube ich
hat lange die gefahr aber auch die
möglichkeiten der digitalen technologien
nicht erkannt man hat seine eigenen
geschäftsfelder und stärken und hat sich
halt gesagt man kauft ein wo man nicht
so stark ist und lange zeit hat das ja
auch funktioniert bis man dann gemerkt
hat dass man eigentlich verwundbare ist
ja verwundbar einerseits in der
geschäftswelt gibt wahrscheinlich fast
kein unternehmen wo die computer nicht
schon gehackt worden so das gab auf dem
letzten werken damit forum wo ein zitat
es gibt solche firmen die gehackt worden
sind solche die es noch nicht wissen und
cyberkriminalität hat nun ein ausmaß
angenommen das kostet 3 milliarden
dollar pro jahr und steigt weiter
exponentiell
aber gleichzeitig gibt es auch noch das
problem des möglichen cyber wars das
heißt dass unsere kritischen
infrastrukturen einfach abgeschaltet
werden könnten und der manipuliert
werden könnten
und das sind natürlich unglaublich
gefahren mit denen man sich nun
auseinandersetzen muss insofern stellt
sich schon die frage ja kann man sich da
so stark von anderer technik abhängig
machen ja wir wissen dass die cloud
nicht mehr sicher ist dass die hart ist
nicht mehr sicher sind dass sie
verschlüsselungstechniken nicht mehr
sicher sind damit auch die
finanztransfers neulich wurde eine
milliarde mit einem cyber crime die von
banken gestohlen also es ist schon
gefährlich immer mehr passt darf uns auf
und wir hier sind sie das nein ich meine
im grunde genommen
da müssen wir alle auf uns aufpassen
aber der staat hat natürlich eine
besondere verantwortung für uns ja und
hatte die hat dass die polizei diesen
polizei die die mittel hat die justiz
die mittel um einzugreifen
na ja es werden ja neue gesetze
geschaffen die ganze zeit die frage ist
ob das der richtige ansatz ist den hier
verfolgen ja aus meiner sicht ist es so
dass es eigentlich zwei mögliche
ausformungen gibt der digitalen
gesellschaft die eine ist sozusagen die
top down variante wo man alle
informationen zentral sammelt das sie
wollen so wie es funktioniert das ist
das was wir eigentlich zunehmend sehen
ja und ich glaube das müssen wir daher
auch noch mal diskutieren ob das
tatsächlich gut ist oder was die
gefahren sind für unsere gesellschaft
und dann gibt es die möglichkeit der
bottom up koordination also das jetzt
informationstechnologien uns bürgern
helfen
mit einander eben dinge zu koordinieren
unsere nachbarschaft unsere
wirtschaftlichen aktivitäten in zukunft
werden uns vielleicht selber
beschäftigen müssen weil wir viele
arbeitsplätze verloren gehen werden und
das in die zwei verschiedenen
alternativen und die müssen wir jetzt
mal gedanklich durchspielen sehr gerne
aber vielleicht doch am anfang weil wir
noch bei der bei der privatsphäre wahren
und wenn man von unten nach oben also
wenn ich muss ja wieder vertrauen haben
in dieses system der informations ja und
das heißt ich muss für meine daten
selber zuständig sein oder ich muss eine
wie eine ein selber entscheiden können
was mit diesen daten passiert ja es gibt
ein sehr interessantes urteil das ich
empfehle zu lesen das
volkszählungsurteil in deutschland das
hat sich genau mit dieser frage
beschäftigt wie wichtig ist eigentlich
informationelle selbstbestimmung nicht
nur für den einzelnen für die
selbstentfaltung sondern auch für die
gesellschaft und das ergebnis ist sie
ist essentiell tatsächlich für das
gemeinwohl auch und das haben wir
heutzutage nicht umgesetzt wir haben
eigentlich keinen überblick über all die
informationen die wir uns gesammelt
werden was mit denen informationen
gemacht wird um das zu ändern also um
unsere demokratischen grundrechte
umzusetzen müsste man hier eine
technologie entwickeln die man oft als
persönliches daten postfach bezeichnet
also da würden alle daten die über einen
anfall in dieses postfach geschickt
werden müssen das ist wer in mind
ressort milliarde ein datentresor wo
alle persönlichen daten hin geschickt
wurden und dann ist es so dass man das
administrieren kann man könnte also zum
beispiel einstellen dass meine shopping
daten von unternehmen zugegriffen werden
können damit die mir interessante
angebote machen können
oder ich könnte einstellen dass ich
meine sozialen medien daten meine
kontakte teilen möchte mit meinen
freunden und meine medizinischen daten
mit meinem hausarzt und dann gibt es
vielleicht irgendwelche daten die ich
mit ihm landen
aber das heißt auch ich könnte meine
daten auch verkaufen also ich sagen
genau dass es eigentlich die perspektive
auf die es hinausläuft es gibt vom world
economic forum
ein bericht der anfield eben tatsächlich
die persönliche selbstbestimmung zu
stärken aber eben auch die bürger fair
an den wirtschaftlichen gewinnen die man
mit ihren persönlichen daten erzielt zu
beteiligen und damit wurden natürlich
auch hier neue einnahmequellen für den
bürger entstehen wie brauche es weil wir
gesagt in zukunft viele klassische jobs
verloren gehen werden und insofern
müssen wir es tatsächlich darauf
konzentrieren um uns gesellschaft stabil
zu halten dass hier neue möglichkeiten
für neue jobs und für die bürger
entstehen also heißt ich werde meine
kleine daten firma und kann mit meinen
daten dörnen jetzt gibt es vielleicht
noch eine frage kann ich auch daten
löschen
also bringen das sollte eigentlich
möglich sein oder man macht es so dass
die daten standardmäßig verschlüsselt
sind und dass die daten gar nicht
sichtbar sind die nicht aufgeschlossen
werden ja also sicherlich kann man
darüber verschiedene technologische
varianten diskutieren dann gibt es
natürlich leute die sich in diesen
details sondern besser auskennen als ich
aber jedenfalls ist sie handlungsbedarf
und soweit ich das übersehe gibt es da
auch weitgehend einigkeit zwischen
politik wissenschaft und wirtschaft und
den bürgern also informationelle
selbstbestimmung ist quasi wirklich im
kerngebiet wo handlungsbedarf besteht
gibt es den alternativen dass man sagt
wenn man jetzt alles freigeben würde
einfach auch also ich habe das bei
jeremy rifkin gelesen man
dann sagen alles ist frei privatsphäre
sowieso eine relativ junge erfindung
ganz lange hat die menschheit ohne dass
gelebt wir löschen das jetzt mal was
raus und dann plötzlich sackt sie gar
der ganze ökonomische druck sagt
zusammen und dann haben wir ein ganz
neues spielfeld für uns ja das ist eine
variante aber ich bin mir nicht so
sicher ob wirklich sieht totale
transparenz die lösung ist dann letzten
endes ist es so minderheiten sind immer
verwundbar aber andererseits baut uns
gesellschaft doch sehr stark auf
minderheiten auf ja ich meine politiker
sind minderheiten milliardärs in
minderheiten intellektuelle künstler
viele geschichten ja auch juristen ja da
möchte man eigentlich nicht dass druck
ausgeübt wird
sie müssen tatsächlich unabhängig nach
ihrem besten wissen gewissen agieren
können damit sie den größten nutzen für
die gesellschaft aber sorgen diese
vorstellung war also wenn man also das
sammeln und von oben nach unten sehr
streng hierarchisch klassisch wie man
das eben das kennt wie es funktioniert
über den staat über über die führungen
und jetzt von unten käme so etwas wie
eine bewegung müsste das ja sein oder
etwas was wir alle zusammen wollen wer
könnte solche prozesse in bewegung
setzen sind das dann wieder neue formen
von kollektiven also nicht kleine
minderheiten die einzelkämpfer sondern
dass man sich irgendwann seinen common
sense begibt und sagt jetzt wollen wir
von unten nach oben wachsen
ja ich denke diese dinge passieren
tatsächlich auch schon ja
die kann man natürlich nicht irgendwie
forcieren ja die kann man nur sozusagen
unterstützen durch entsprechende
technologien die es dann eben einfacher
machen dass sich leute selber
organisieren dass sie ihre nachbarschaft
schöner macht dann ihr berufliches
umfeld irgendwie besser organisieren
können und vielleicht auch tatsächlich
irgendwann smart cities und natrium
gesellschaften gemeinsamen gestalten
können das gibt natürlich ein bereich wo
die politik und die wirtschaft nicht
hinreichen ja dass das ist eben
tatsächlich die untere ebene des bürgers
da sind viele unausgeschöpfte potenziale
also es gibt zum beispiel ein
strategiepapier von der new york times
das sagt dass der leser eigentlich der
am schlechtesten genutzte ressource ist
ja darum ist das jetzt plötzlich so
früher war wir kunden ja ja wir tragen
im grunde genommen
zu dem informationsfluss bei wir
kommentieren die nachrichten
wir verbinden die nachrichten
miteinander wir verbreiten nachrichten
und so weiter und so fort
und so werden wir das in allen
verschiedenen lebensbereichen haben also
bürger werden
wichtig werden um bessere produkte zu
entwickeln im laufe der zeit werden also
unternehmen lernen besser herauszufinden
für welche produkte und
produkteigenschaften wir uns wirklich
interessieren es gibt es auch
plattformen wo man konsumenten die
möglichkeit gibt es selber produkte mit
zu gestalten ja aber das sind ja alles
jetzt sozusagen die verheißungen der von
von big data was man mit den
informationen machen kann die gefahren
haben wir kurz skizziert aber so lange
durch wir zweifeln müssen solange das
von oben nach unten geht und so lange
ich über meine eigene privatsphäre nicht
verfügen kann
sind doch hier die zweifel um die
präsenz und das heißt solange würde ich
mitspielen wollen bei irgendwelchen
versuchen mit meinen daten oder noch
nicht mich selber als als firma und
meine daten als gut verkaufen wo wann
wie passiert dieser shift und wo treffen
sich diese beiden sphären und ist er ja
vielleicht noch ein wort herr
privatsphäre zunächst da gibt es ja in
amerika nie weit verbreitete meinung
dass es ein veraltetes konzept sei
und letzten endes sei jetzt an sein ende
kommt ich glaube nicht dass die
privatsphäre eine versehentliche
konzession an den bürger war sozusagen
ein erzähler und jetzt müsste man das
wieder korrigieren um sozusagen die
möglichkeiten von daten für die
gesellschaften die wirtschaft zu nutzen
privatsphäre
aus meiner sicht ist ein wichtiges
funktionsprinzip der gesellschaft also
öffentlichkeit ist sozusagen die
kehrseite der medaille zur privatheit
die können nicht unabhängig voneinander
funktionieren wenn es keine privatheit
mehr gebe dann gebe es entweder eine
schamlose gesellschaft oder eine
totalitäre gesellschaft einer
perspektive das ist eine einschätzung
und insofern ist auch in zukunft
privatsphäre wichtig sie ist
insbesondere eben auch der ort wo neue
ideen entstehen können wo man neue
sachen ausprobieren kann und das heißt
es wichtige voraussetzung für die
innovation ist das eine alternative zur
überwachung geben also solange es
überwachung gibt ja ich versuche ich
zurück zu krebs in meine privatsphäre zu
schützen
ja ich denke tatsächlich dass unsere
gesellschaft auch in zukunft auf
vertrauen aufbauen muss ja eine
wirtschaft und eine gesellschaft ohne
vertrauen funktioniert nicht wurde auch
gesagt
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser
und in diese richtung laufen wir aber
das erscheint mir ein grosser irrtum zu
sein und man kann die finanzkrise im
grunde genommen als beispiel für eine
vertrauenskrise deuten und die hat uns
so 10.000 milliarden dollar gekostet
und insofern kann man sehen wie viel
unsichtbare faktoren wie vertrauen jetzt
in der mann bezeichnet das oft als eine
form von sozialem kapital und insofern
muss man eigentlich mehr mit der frage
beschäftigen ja wie viel wert sind
eigentlich diese unsichtbaren kräfte die
unsere gesellschaft zusammenhalten die
über erfolg oder misserfolg entscheiden
und mit diesen dingen beschäftigen wir
uns an meiner professor also da geht es
letzten endes nicht darum die welt top
down zu bauen ja so wie wir das gewohnt
sind das verstehen wir gut ja das ist
sozusagen das prinzip der ikea
bauanleitung ja eine lange anleitung die
genau sagt dass sie machen müssen und
wir wissen aufnehmen und das klappt
nicht so richtig es gibt aber eben auch
einen völlig anderen ansatz der auch zu
sozialer ordnung führt und der basiert
auf selbstorganisation auf der
interaktion zwischen den verschiedenen
systemen komponenten sind eben die
bürger
die firmen und so weiter und so fort
eine ökonomie hat diese denkweise auch
eine lange tradition ist dort bekannt
unter dem stichwort die unsichtbare hand
nun wissen wir heutzutage die
unsichtbare hand funktioniert leider
nicht immer aber wenn sie funktioniert
ist es sehr effizient so viel
effizienter als diese top down planung
und optimierung
insofern muss man sich jetzt fragen
unter welchen voraussetzungen
funktioniert die top down planung gut
die optimierung und wann brauchen hier
die selbstorganisation ja aber im moment
glauben wir sozusagen daran dass scheint
so der trend zu sein dass mit dieser
super intelligenz jetzt mehr und mehr
verfügbar wird irgendwann in der
perspektive alles perfekt von oben herab
und gesteuert werden kann also wie ein
weißer könig im grunde genommen wenn man
nur genügend information hat dass das
ist die idee und von der idee her
scheint es auch sehr plausibel zu sein
und das ist die art und weise wie
singapur funktioniert das gilt
heutzutage für viele staaten als vorbild
weil es hat eine enorme entwicklung
zurückgelegt innerhalb von kurzer zeit
große ökonomische wachstumsraten und so
weiter und insofern wird oft die frage
gestellt sind nicht unsere demokratien
veraltet brauchen wir nicht was neues
und wenn man sich anschaut wie groß die
staatsschulden sind dann könnte man
vielleicht zu dem schluss kommen ja so
können wir das auf die dauer nicht
weiter machen wir müssen effizienter
werden es muss sich etwas ändern ist
aber dieses ändern
in welchem zeitrahmen das wie viel zeit
bleibt uns um etwas zu ändern
ich denke wir begann tatsächlich in
wenigen jahren dramatische änderungen
sehen ja zehn zwanzig dreißig jahre und
in dieser zeit werden viele
institutionen grundlegend anders
organisiert werden in diesem
zusammenhang spielt dann vielleicht auch
das tesa
dienstleistungsvertrag den man zwischen
verschiedenen ländern abschließt dann
eine rolle was ist das das ist letzten
endes ein globales oder nicht ganz
global ist aber ein internationales
abkommen wo es um dienstleistungen geht
die unternehmen anbieten können unter
anderem eben auch aus anderen ländern
also es wäre also denkbar dass die
personalbuchhaltung finanzbuchhaltung
eines unternehmens aus einem anderen
land gemacht wird oder vielleicht sogar
eine verwaltung aus einem anderen land
organisiert wird ja so kann ich mir das
vorstellen ist nichts genaues bekannt
über den vertrag aber es werden auf
jeden fall völlig andere organisation
sind denk dinge die schon passieren also
unsere informatikern der schweiz dieses
jahr auf das indien also es ist das ist
schon so ja ich denke dass da
erdrutschartige entwicklung tatsächlich
auch vorgehen kann
wir sehen das jetzt heutzutage mit tuba
und airbnb zum beispiel ja wo manche
leute jetzt sehr erschrocken reagieren
darüber dass auf einmal der taxi markt
oder eben auch der markt der
übernachtung von geschäftsleuten oder
eben auch touristen völlig umgekrempelt
wird innerhalb von wenigen jahren und
zwar auch mit einer großen
rücksichtslosigkeit da gibt es
gerichtsbeschlüsse in heiligen stätten
die führen über völlig ignoriert werden
ja und insofern muss man schon damit
rechnen dass diese urbanisierung in
vielen bereichen der gesellschaft
stattfinden könnte und dass am ende
monopole unter umständen ganze bereiche
bis hin eben auch zu bereichen
kontrollieren die vielleicht früher
öffentlich verwaltet puncto puncto
kontrolle da wären wir vielleicht bei
ihrem fachgebiet
komplexen systeme sie haben kontrolle
geschaffen in mekka um die pilgerströme
zu leiten funktioniert ja also es ist
gleich mal ganz interessant sich
anzuschauen wie das dort gemacht wurde
da wurden viele maßnahmen ergriffen
zunächst einmal wurden kreuzende ströme
von pilgern und gegenverkehr vermieden
um sozusagen reibung aus dem system auch
sie vermessen sie das oder ist wie es
ist einmal eine andere weise wie die
straßen genutzt werden oder die wg titel
zu der jammer radbrücke führen wo eben
diese religiösen rituale ablaufen
aber es wird natürlich letzten endes
gemessen wie viele leute unterwegs sind
auf den straßen und wenn die kapazität
ausgelastetes kurz bevor das der fall
ist gibt es quasi eine warnung und dann
reagiert man adaptiv auf diese
echtzeitinformationen indem man
pilgerströme umleitet also
informationssysteme sind hier äußerst
wichtig für eine echtzeit anpassung an
die jeweilige lage und jetzt komplexeres
system es eine wirtschaftskrise zu
verhindern zum beispiel ist man sind sie
da in der lage das also vielleicht
sollten wir noch mal kurz bevor wir auf
diese dezentralen ansatz eingehen
diese idee mit diesem weisen könig noch
vor uns durchspielen ja also zunächst
einmal hört sich das sehr plausibel an
wenn man nur alle informationen hätte
dann könnte man ja doch immer die besten
lösungen finden und die könnte man dann
umsetzen top down und im grunde genommen
vielleicht würde man das als bürger gar
nicht so sehr spüren denn wir werden
heutzutage in unsere zeit und immer mehr
beeinflusst durch informationssysteme
personalisierte informationen die wir
auf dem handy
der suchanfragen oder wenn wir nach
einer urlaubsreise suchen oder so
bekommen und über diese personalisierten
informationen könnten wir im prinzip ist
ein gewissen grade gesteuert werden ja
dass das möglich ist das wissen wir aus
der werbung als wir sind beeinflussbar
und das könnte man im grunde genommen
auch in der politik anwenden das nennt
sich nacho ja dass man sozusagen den
bürger so einen kleinen stups gibt in
eine richtung wie man das haben möchte
und er würde sich dann vielleicht
umweltfreundlicher verhalten oder was
auch immer
das hört sich jetzt zunächst einmal aus
sicht des staates sehr plausibel an
setzt aber voraus dass der staat immer
beurteilen kann was tatsächlich das
beste ist und eine frage die da enorm
hineinspielt sage ich die frage welche
ziel funktion wählt man was optimiert
man letzten endes und da muss man sich
für etwas entscheiden
das heißt man wenn man sich entscheidet
das ist ein kollektiver entscheid dieser
kollektive entscheid muss auf eine art
von kompetenz basieren also das heißt
man muss verstehen verstehen und wenn
man es nicht versteht weiß man nicht wo
man ansetzen muss wenn dieses system
dermaßen kompliziert ist dass selbst die
wissenschaftler darauf wollte ich
eigentlich vorherigen hinaus dass man
sagt man kann verkehrs verkehr kann man
leiten das diesem ansinnen die von allen
wenn jetzt aber komplexere systeme nicht
durch den apparat oder die maschine
kontrollierbar sind durch die daten
kontrollierbar sind dann sind jedoch
permanent in einem extremen risiko
bringen
das dass wir eigentlich von anfang an
verhindern wollten
darauf wollte ich ihn als also zunächst
einmal leistungsfähige
informationssystemen können natürlich zu
globalen entscheidungen führen
und wenn die sich als falsch
herausstellen im nachhinein ja dann kann
das natürlich katastrophale auswirkungen
haben
ja der maßstab in dem sozusagen dann
auch die maßnahmen ablaufen ist das ein
temporäres haarkranz krise zum beispiel
hätten sie mit genügend daten und hätten
sie den auftrag gehabt hätten sie
verhindern können
ja so weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen
aber auf die frage von problemen wie
konflikten usw
würde ich nachher tatsächlich gerne noch
müssen eingehen ja aber vielleicht noch
mal diese limitation dieses reisen
königs also erstens mal das problem ist
die richtigen daten zu haben die
richtigen schlüsse zu ziehen
in vielen fällen wird es nicht der fall
sein die richtige ziel funktionieren das
ist natürlich im letzten punkt ein
politischer entscheid darüber müssen
dann eigentlich die öffentlichen
diskussionen geführt werden was von
überhaupt optimieren wenn wir das
falsche operieren kann das katastrophal
also jemand zu sein wer ist dieser weise
könig ja das ist natürlich das ist das
ist dass das ist die große frage aber
worauf ich hinaus will ist das ist
meiner meinung nach eben nicht
funktioniert denn viele probleme die wir
tatsächlich in unserer wirklichkeit
haben sind nicht von der art dass sie in
echtzeit optimiert werden können also
unterdessen verkehr ist zum beispiel
noch einmal google haben der verkehr kam
nicht in echtzeit kontrolliert werden
das ist so also wenn wir tatsächlich
alle möglichen ampelschaltungen durch
probieren wollten in echtzeit um
herauszufinden was die beste an
beschaltung ist dann könnten das super
computer heutzutage immer noch nicht
lösen
das liegt an der starken variabilität
des verkehrs aber das mache ich schon
ein bisschen wenn ich hab gedacht das
ist noch ein relativ einzugrenzen und
das komplexe system oder vorherigen
absolut aber wir haben die großen
herausforderung klimawandel
die politische neben die creme krise wir
sind syrien wir sind es wir haben viele
komplexe probleme viele viele daten und
sie sagen wir nein wir kriegen das mit
dem verkehr nicht hin also hab ich doch
sofort mein vertrauen verloren dass wir
die anderen großen baustellen irgendwo
über big data oder über über über die
handhabe mit der daten in den griff
bekommen ja das ist eine frage des
ansatzes also tatsächlich das problem
mit dem auch daten und große
supercomputer nicht zurecht kommen das
ist komplexität ja die komplexität
explodiert im grunde genommen noch
schneller als die datenvolumina und
deswegen brauche ich einen anderen
ansatz
das ist die verteilte steuerung und in
der tat kann man das zeigen dass man den
verkehr auf der autobahn verbessern kann
dramatisch indem man die interaktion
zwischen den fahrzeugen verändert das
kam mit fahrerassistenzsystem machen
genauso kann man im stadtverkehr die art
und weise wie die ampeln geschaltet
werden ändern und zwar auf eine art und
weise dass die verkehrsflüsse die ampeln
schalten statt wie heute die ampeln die
verkehrsflüsse straße funktioniert an
viel besser also es viel effizienter wir
sehen also mittlerweile in der
verkehrssteuerung ein trend weg von
diesen alten telematiklösungen wo man
verkehrs zentren hatten die versuchten
irgendwie alles zu steuern sondern
optimieren hin zu dezentralen lösungen
mit auch fahrzeug fahrzeug kommunikation
und so weiter und so fort
und das müsste uns eigentlich etwas
sagen darüber wie ihr komplexes ist und
das hat auch wenn das hat auch mit dem
internet der dinge zu tun also dass
jedes auto jedes jedes ding ist
miteinander vernetzt das heißt wir
müssten noch mehr also dieses
nervensystem ist dennoch verästelte sein
um diese diese welt simulation
herzustellen
ja es meiner sicht geht es nicht um die
welt simulation aber was ist eigentlich
da ist tatsächlich so sagen
große technologie welle die noch mal
einen schub bringen wird wo also letzten
endes computer und smartphones und
smartbooks und sensoren aller art noch
ins internet einbezogen werden und das
ermöglicht es nun sozusagen unsere
umwelt in echtzeit zu messen und dann
ist die frage was machen wir eigentlich
mit diesen informationen dass ganzen
helfen bewusst zu werden über die
probleme die es gibt aber wir können
diese daten sozusagen auch zurückstellen
auf das system also feedback mechanismen
ein für die wirtschaft für die politik
für die wirtschaft und die politik
zivilgesellschaft genau in allen
bereichen wo wir sozusagen eine
selbststeuerung ermöglichen eine
selbstorganisation und das wäre dann am
lokalen maßstab nach prinzipien wie es
in einer demokratie eben auch haben ja
also mit beteiligung von unten
und dafür brauche es letzten endes nur
lokale interaktionen da brauchst nicht
die globale datenbank
wir brauchen diese daten nur kurz zu
messen
und nachdem wir sie zu sagen nutzen für
diese lokale steuerung können wir sie es
sogar schon wieder wegwerfen das also
völlig anderer ansatz als dieser mit
data ansatz wie wir ihn heute haben wo
wir alle daten der welt an einem ort zu
versammeln versuchen was meiner meinung
nach sehr gefährlich ist weil es kann
eben auch von kriminellen terroristen
extremisten dran wahrscheinlich
genutzten missbraucht werden und
deswegen bin ich sehr stark ein
verfechter der dezentralisierung von
informationssystemen dass es meiner
meinung nach das sicherere ansatz
und letzten endes eben auch vereinbar
mit den prinzipien autonomie und
demokratie die meiner meinung nach
keineswegs veraltete konzeptes in
sondern jetzt konsequenz auch
weiterentwickelt werden müssen
mit den technologischen möglichkeiten
dass wir haben das könnte für uns jetzt
also sie haben vorhin einmal europa
erwähnt oder also wir haben keine großen
ressource aber es könnte eine chance
sein
mit unserer demokratischen mit unserem
demokratischen bewusstseins der
vergangenheit und vor allem vielleicht
für den schweizer speziell weil wir aber
wer hat das auf und ja das könnte ein
schweizerisches thema sei
genau für sie zu groß ich das ja weil
man kann sich eben die schweiz da kann
sich europa eben auch absetzen
mit dieser herangehensweise von anderen
ländern dann wenn wir konkurrieren
wollen im it bereich mit dem rest der
welt da müssen wir unseren eigenen weg
gehen wir können nicht das gleiche 15
jahre später nach was wäre das durchaus
wohnen und das ist schwer zu sagen das
hängt natürlich davon ab wie man das
aufbaut ja ich denke an ein system das
wir das service netzwerk landtages
nervensystem nennen das würde also vom
bürger mit gestaltet werden können so
wie wikipedia zum beispiel oder
openstreetmap und der vorteil wäre also
jeder konnte es selber so nutzen wie er
möchte
aber es wurden eben auch sehr viele
ideen an bord genommen die in der
bevölkerung unter experten nicht
experten vorhanden sind und das würde
alles irgendwie einschließen und dieses
verteilte gemeinsame bürgernetzwerk
wachsen lassen und gelegenheiten für
alle schaffen wer unterstützt ihn bei
der umsetzung dieser vision oder ja dass
das ist die große frage ich denke es
gibt extrem viel interesse so wie ich
das sie in der bevölkerung und der
wissenschaftlern auch durchaus in der
wirtschaft also ich
das ist oft vor auch juristen sind sehr
daran interessiert denn da scheint doch
die lösung zu sein für die probleme die
wir haben für das problem der
komplexität für das problem der
informationelle selbstbestimmung für das
problem tatsächlich autonomie und
demokratie auch im zeitalter dieser
technologischen revolution auch aufrecht
zu erhalten und zu unserem vorteil zu
nutzen ja das ist ja der entscheidende
punkt und sie glauben dass sie als
professor jetzt alle diese ganz diese
bürde tragen können stecken ja dafür
braucht es letzten endes viele leute die
sich daran beteiligen aber ich glaube
schon dass das ein system werden kann
die bei wikipedia wo die leute dann
anfangen mitzumachen
und dazu muss es eben einfach
faszinierend sein es muss das
spielerische element glaube ich und mit
dabei sein und wir werden sehen ob das
funktioniert also natürlich etwas wo man
den ausgang nicht voraussagen kann aber
und ich sage ja schweizer dahinter
folgen aber das habe ich davon wenn ich
da mitmache werde ich werden wir
glücklicher in eine glücklichere zukunft
aufbrechen wo dann wissen wir weil der
druck so hoch ist und es gar keine
alternative
also ich denke das ist das natürlich
sehr gut geht und deutschland aber das
ist deswegen vielleicht auch ein
bisschen die gefahr besteht dass wir
vielleicht als letzte reagieren auf
diese technologische revolution
die anderenorts schon verheerende folgen
gehabt hat ja wir haben ja in vielen
ländern europa schon mehr als 50 prozent
arbeitslosigkeit und wir sollten
eigentlich das geld das wir haben jetzt
nutzen um diese neuen
informationsinfrastrukturen aufzubauen
und den nutzen zu generieren auch die
arbeitsplätze und wenn wir am schluss
und das gespräch nochmals in ihre
kristallkugel die ist ja nicht so gern
haben aber trotzdem in die kristallkugel
schauen kommt es gut
oder kommt es nicht gut ich glaube das
wird wirklich eine faszinierende sache
die allen helfen
der politik der wirtschaft den bürger
der wissenschaft also wir alle und
insbesondere der bürger können von
diesem system am meisten profitieren hey
wenn ich danke ihnen für das gespräch
die heutige sternstunde philosophie ist
vorbei wollen sie gleich ein marshmallow
zur belohnung oder lieber später 2 wenn
sie erfahren wollen warum ein belohnungs
aufschub ihre chancen auf ein besseres
leben erhöht dann schauen sie nächste
woche das gespräch von stephan klapproth
mit den berühmten psychologen walter
michel
[Musik]